in the Senegalese capital dakar the
former Palace of Justice has been
converted to house the month-long show
that features contemporary African art
Oh linear Rasheeda Candia a Nigerian
artist living in the u.s. is putting up
his installation from everyday materials
such as cardboard fabric and plastic his
work is an existential reflection of
post-colonial Africa combined with
political and environmental issues it's
a vivid complex creation and materials
that I use are boxes which people throw
away which I cut into pieces and then
also the collections of the slide which
come from different pieces of different
people which I put together to form a
kind of thing so we look like more like
a net but the idea was I'll connect our
connection our link we had to each other
another question which I'm hosting
myself especially with this connection
was to look at what where are we as
Africans where are we now
are we stick crawling are we still
working or I've already start standing
up or we are started working the
Biennale invited 65 artists
what started as a literature festival 20
years ago in Dakar has morphed into
Africa's largest Contemporary Art Fair
lesbian l did the can a la partie bonala
of the car focuses on contemporary art
for both artists in Africa and those in
the Diaspora cool so it's important that
it takes place in the continent landmark
cultural event for the visual arts it's
11 market or el mejor de pontignac or
laser vision the work of Victor at you
comin or another Nigerian artist deals
with the stark changes in his country he
grew up in a society largely influenced
by mythology and religion his
installation is a kind of prayer room
that recreates the world of his
childhood you know places like this they
are all going extinct now you probably
won't find them anymore but I was lucky
enough as a kid to find places like this
where people could go for prayers could
good for definition could good for
prophecy you know so that is what I've
created here and the sculpted paintings
are representation of people that go in
there the kind of clothes they would
wear the kind of colors that is vibrant
as traditions give way to technology
some old ways of life are dying out
while new lifestyles are still being
defined these are the kinds of questions
about transition posed by the dark art
Biennale in Senegal